es war eine geheime wahl unter drei
kandidaten das kfd so agiert hat wie
reagiert hat können sie selber bewerten
ich kann nur nochmals betonen die
brandmauern gegenüber die afd bleiben
bestehen mit einem ministerpräsidenten
kemmerich wird es kein angebot keine
koalition keine miss ministerien und
auch keine afd politik geben wenn sie
versucht das amt des ministerpräsidenten
und meine wahl damit zu beschädigen
hat sie mit mir einen erbitterten gegner
gewählt für die politik da fd ich bin
anti afd ich bin anträge im parlament
gibt es nicht das was wir im politischen
geübten zusammenspiel als mehrheiten
natürliche art kennen
ich denke es geht mehr als den jung die
sache und wenn wir überhaupt über
inhalte uns an problematik hin an
lösungsansätze nähern dann sind all
diejenigen die auch an cdu und an die
fdp in den letzten wochen und monaten
gerichtete aufforderung bestellt haben
sich der verantwortung zu stellen der
staatspolitischen die verantwortungs
aufforderung geben jetzt zurück wenn sie
mich zur linken konkrete fragen auch sie
haben in ihrer programmatik dinge die
nicht in meinen augen mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft mit den grundsätzen
unserer demokratie vereinbar sind
ich habe mich an einer geheimen
abstimmung im landtag gestellt
das ist das gute recht eines demokraten